rusia mantiene la tensión sobre el
carrera mientras espera el próximo
movimiento del presidente yo wide en
moscú ha acusado a quiet de mover a
artillería pesada hacia la línea del
frente y mientras tanto putin e incluso
ha dicho que lo que está sucediendo en
bombas la zona de conflicto en el este
de ucrania ahora mismo se asemeja a los
primeros pasos hacia un genocidio el
momento más tenso de las últimas horas
ha sido cuando un buque de guerra
ucraniano se ha dirigido hacia el
estrecho de kerch que separa rusia y la
península anexionada de crimea el barco
no respondía a los llamamientos rusos
para que cambiase su rumbo aunque
finalmente parece que se ha dado la
vuelta moscú compara estas tensiones en
bombas y en la zona con la situación que
se vivió entre kennedy y kruschev con la
crisis de los misiles durante los años
60 por cierto que yo vaya de aníbal eddy
merckx selenski han hablado hoy sobre
cómo va a recibir ucrania apoyo político
económico y militar además el presidente
ucraniano seresesky ha dicho a yo vayan
que tiene varias propuestas concretas
para impulsar el proceso en ucrania